nokia danone total general electric
brixton ces entreprises ont elles
profité de la crise sanitaire pour
procéder à des plans sociaux ces
derniers mois ils étaient des milliers à
défiler dans la rue pour sauver leur
emploi depuis l'instauration du premier
confinement en mars dernier l'économie
française et mondiale est mise à mal
avec une chute conséquente du pib si le
gouvernement a mis en place un plan de
relance de l'économie est octroyé les
mesures de chômage partiel à plus d'un
million d'entreprises
cela n'a pas empêché la multiplication
des plans sociaux
bien au contraire la gronde se fait de
plus en plus entendre du côté de general
electric ce mardi plus de 70 employés en
grève ont manifesté devant bercy et
l'assemblée nationale pour contester le
plan social qui prévoit la suppression
de 350 postes sur les sites de
villeurbanne et de saint priest près de
lyon
des multinationales qui se ferait sur la
vague kovy 19 c'est le sentiment qu'on
les syndicats ces derniers demandent à
ce que les subventions versées par
l'état afin de sauvegarder l'emploi
certes à trouver une alternative au plan
social à béthune dans le pas de calais
les salariés du géant du pneu
bridgestone se mobilisent sans relâche
pour tenter de stopper la fermeture du
site qui entraînera la suppression de 8
163 postes en avril 2021
les syndicats appellent quant à eux un
durcissement du ton du gouvernement face
aux entreprises et aux multinationales
qui estime que la crise sanitaire est
une aubaine et une opportunité pour
licencier danone a bénéfi cient dette
publique et annonce des suppressions
d'emplois pour favoriser la
compétitivité rassurer les actionnaires
comme bridgestone les entreprises comme
danone sont très habiles pour faire leur
marché sur les aides publiques
c'est inacceptable il faut que le
gouvernement soit beaucoup plus strictes
quant à l'octroi des aides publiques
le 10 septembre dernier bruno le maire
avait assuré au sénat de vouloir
employer tous les moyens
vous refusez ses plans sociaux d'aubaine
en appelant les entreprises à faire
preuve d'un sens des responsabilités